CHET HAASE: Good afternoon, and
welcome to the first session,
right?
What's New In Android?
The session that I like
to think of as the Android
keynote for the people
that couldn't actually
wake up that early.
So congratulations for
actually waking up this early.
We'll see how it goes.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, well done.
Give yourselves a hand.
Absolutely.
This is a talk
that traditionally
has been done by
me and Romain Guy,
who could not make it this year
because we didn't ask him to.
Though we did get an
appropriate stand-in for Romain.
We found someone that can
fake a decent French accent.
DAN SANDLER: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
Eiffel Tower.
CHET HAASE: So with that,
let's introduce ourselves,
because obviously you
have no idea who we are.
I am Chet Haase.
I am on the UI Toolkit
team in Android.
DAN SANDLER: I'm Dan Sandler.
I'm on the Android
System UI team.
CHET HAASE: That accent
didn't last very long.
DAN SANDLER: It didn't.
I couldn't.
CHET HAASE: All right, so one
of the questions that comes up--
it just came up at
lunchtime, actually,
down in the cafeteria-- is
OK, so there's an L release.
What does L stand for?
And I'm here to
tell you-- can we
have like, a drum
roll, or something?
[AUDIENCE ATTEMPTS DRUM ROLL]
L if I know.
But for today, we are calling
this the L Developer Preview
release.
We heard about this
in the keynote,
and we can see by the graphics
on the screen that aren't quite
professionally done that
it is not a final release.
It is instead a preview release
where things work pretty well,
but it's not done yet.
We're hard at work
finishing the L release.
And in the meantime,
we're exposing it to you
to actually use in the meantime,
get your apps running and happy
on it, and most
importantly, to send us
feedback about what's not
working exactly perfectly
so that we can actually
nail that down by the time
we ship it.
So in the meantime
today, we wanted
to give a session talking
about all the bits
that are new in
this preview release
that you can get your
hands on and play with,
and there's a lot
of material in here.
We'll see how fast--
DAN SANDLER: We have about
six hours of material
to cover in 45 minutes, so
you're gonna have to hang on.
CHET HAASE: So
first of all, let's
start with graphics
and UI, because I
like to start with
graphics and UI,
and I usually like to
end with that as well.
So we heard about the material
design stuff in the keynote,
and we wanted to touch on
a couple of those elements
in here.
I also want to point
out, I'll give you
references at the
end of this section,
about where to go
for more information
during the conference.
In fact, one of the whole
points of this session
is to give you just a little
bit more detailed info on all
of the feature areas that
we find interesting to talk
about, and also the
references to what
other sessions and what other
videos you should check out,
or sandboxes that have
further information,
or where you can simply
find Diane on the show floor
if you want to ask her directly.
So in the material area,
we have a new theme,
we have some new
widgets for you,
and we also have
some new APIs, which
you can use at your option.
The theme exposes new colors.
There's an idea
in material design
that all the assets are
by default grayscale,
and then they can be tinted.
So it's very easy to
brand your application,
or your application
state, with colors,
as opposed to baking the colors
directly into the assets.
So that's much easier now.
There's new icons out there.
Some of them are
animated, part of
the rich interactive
experience that we have.
With material design, we
have touch feedback ripples.
We'll see a little bit
more about-- give the user
a sense of interacting
with the UI
and knowing exactly what's
going on in the UI at all times.
And also, activity transitions
with shared hero elements.
We'll see a little
bit more about that.
In the widget space,
we have a couple
of widgets that
are very important.
One of them is minor.
It's CardView.
There's not a lot there.
It's basically a container
with rounded corners,
and it's raised up off the view
hierarchy plane a little bit
to give a shadowed look to it.
This is not something that's
too hard to do in your own code,
but having CardView there
allows you to have this look
and feel in a consistent way
that other applications are
using it as well.
RecyclerView is a
little bit larger.
If we can actually just
do an informal poll of
who has actually used ListView?
OK.
If I can just count.
Hang on.
OK, so that was basically
everyone in the audience.
Now if we can get a
count of the people
who have enjoyed
that experience?
I count two, which is actually
one more than I expected.
So you can think of
RecyclerView as being ListView2.
This is more extensible,
more flexible.
We have layout managers
that you can plug in
to get different layouts.
It's amazing.
You can actually
linearly lay out
both vertically
and horizontally.
Incredible.
[CHEERING]
DAN SANDLER: Absolutely.
CHET HAASE: Because
on the Android team,
we think not only about why,
but also about X. So we have--
[GROANING]
We have a linear--
why the groan?
We have a linear layout
manager in there right now.
We have some other
layout managers
that we're working on that
will come out with it,
or you can write your own
custom layout manager.
There's also animations
baked into it.
Some very simple add remove
animations right now.
I don't know if
anybody has actually
tried to implement
animations in ListView.
I know I personally have
done several videos trying
to explain how to do this
nearly impossible task.
What we'd like is for that
to simply be automatic,
so we've started down
the road for that.
And both of these,
most importantly,
unlike a lot of the new
APIs, which are obviously
just part of the L
release, these widgets
are actually in the
support library in V7.
So you can use those--
[APPLAUSE]
DAN SANDLER: How much
did you pay them?
We're getting a lot of
applause lines here.
CHET HAASE: I actually don't
know what they're clapping at.
It has nothing to do
with what I'm saying.
Something else is going on--
DAN SANDLER: World Cup.
CHET HAASE: So you can use those
in your material applications,
in your L applications,
but you can also
use them in code for
earlier releases as well.
So have at it.
Also, in the graphics area, we
have real time soft shadows.
We heard a little bit
about that in the keynote.
We'll hear more tomorrow
in some sessions tomorrow.
It's the ability to give
elevation to views to pop them
up off the view hierarchy plane.
Not only giving them
elevation and Z value,
and then allowing them to cast
a shadow, a soft shadow based
on that elevation, but also
to draw outside their bounds.
One of the tricky parts about
doing things like shadows
is, or if you want to
scale that view, well,
then you need to
tell the containment
hierarchy of that
view not to clip it.
Well, giving it elevation pops
it into-- what you can picture
is like an aquarium,
a 3D volume that
sits on top of the
view hierarchy.
And all of a sudden, you've
got much more flexibility
about how that thing is
drawn, about how it's clipped,
and about the ordering with
which it and its shadow
is drawn in the hierarchy.
We have animations.
Yay, more animation stuff.
The biggest one in this area
is activity transitions--
in particular, the
ability to share
elements between activities.
So we've seen some work.
I think it was last year at I/O
there was an animation talk,
and there was some
"DevBytes" around this
where we showed techniques
for passing information
between activities such that
you could pass information
about elements, and you could
sort of fake this animation
to look like it
transitions seamlessly
from one activity to another.
So that technique has been
baked into the platform,
so there's a standard
API way for you
to say this is my shared
[INAUDIBLE] element,
or a set of shared
elements, and you
can pass those
between activities,
and they can share them.
They can animate them
between the activities.
You can animate other items in
and out between the activities,
and you can customize
the entire experience,
making it all part of the
material idea of making all
the transitions
seamless for the user
as they go from state to state
to state in their application,
or in your application.
Also, there's new animation
curve capabilities, both motion
and timing curves,
so you can have
a much more custom path-based
curve in the timing area.
You can also move
things in x and y
along a curve, which
is a little bit tricky.
Possible, but tricky before.
And finally, there's
animated reveal capabilities.
So you can reveal the next
state of an activity or a view
by having a circular reveal
that exposes it over time.
And I think there's a video
of some of this stuff.
So this is sort of an
epilepsy-causing animation
here that I looped, just showing
some of the shared element
transition stuff where we're
popping the view in and out.
If you look closely,
you can see a shadow
that's popped as
we're elevating it.
And then as it goes back
down to the view hierarchy,
we launch the next activity
and pass that view over
as the shared element between
these two separate activities.
We have some new
icon capabilities.
There's a couple
of different ways
of animating states in icons.
One of them you see in the
check boxes and radio buttons,
the ability to basically
animate key frames,
or these images that
represent an animation
from one state to another.
And there's another one
called StateListAnimator,
where when you go from
one state to another,
you can specify a
custom animation that
will animate
properties over time.
And then finally, we have
touch feedback ripples,
which gives the user indication
of what's going on in the UI
when they press that button.
It's not simply going
from unpressed to pressed,
but it's actually
giving them information
about the gradual state
change that's occurring,
as well as possibly where
that state change occurred.
So if we look at the
video here, let's
see if-- that is really
hard to see on this screen.
There's some subtle ripples
on the button down below,
and you can see the
ripples are actually
emanating from the
touch point that I
had when I touched this
beautiful button in my UI.
And then the check box
up at the top, that's
one of the animated
PNG animations
that we have for the
AnimatedStateListDrawable.
And render thread.
So this is kind of an
implementation detail,
but it's a really
interesting one,
so I'm going to talk
about it anyway.
And it's also important, and
probably increasingly important
as we go forward,
for performance.
One of the issues that we
have with UI and graphics
animations, and performance
in UIs in general and Android,
is that everything needs to stay
on the UI toolkit thread, which
means if you're doing
something silly like querying
a web service on your UI
thread, A, don't, and B,
you're going to freeze your UI.
And C, see A before.
Don't do that.
But you can get yourself
into these positions,
in some cases
necessarily, because that
is an operation we need to
perform in the UI toolkit
thread, and therefore
everything else happening halts.
A really great example of that
is when you launch an activity,
then we need to inflate
that new activity
if you're in the same process
on the UI toolkit thread.
Well, in the meantime, if
you're running an animation that
also needs to run in
the UI toolkit thread,
then that animation
is going to stop
while the activity launches.
So we came along with the
render thread technology
to be able to break apart the
two processes of rendering.
There's the creating the
display list of what we actually
want to render, and
then there's actually
executing that display
list and telling the GPU
how to draw this stuff.
And we broke these two apart.
So we create it on
the UI toolkit thread,
where it necessarily
has to be, and then we
pass that information over
the wall to the render thread
to let it actually execute
and talk to the GPU
on a separate thread.
In particular,
what we want to do
is take these atomic
animations and send them over
so they can perform completely
autonomously on the render
thread so that now you're not
beholden to the state of the UI
toolkit thread if you
are inflating an activity
or doing an expensive operation,
because the animations can
happen asynchronously
at the same time.
So we've started down
that path right now.
There's going to be more
work going forward on that.
A great visual
example of that right
now is the touch
feedback ripples,
which happen on
the render thread,
and they happen completely
autonomous of the UI toolkit
thread, which is why when
you click on something that
launches a new activity, the
ripple continues to actually
animate while the new
activity window is coming up.
There's some important
I/O talks where
we go into a lot more gory
detail in a lot of this stuff,
so I would suggest that
you check those out.
Some of them are, of
course, the material
design talks themselves.
They're scattered
throughout the conference,
and I frankly didn't look
up the names and titles,
so they're not on this slide.
There are two
sessions in particular
that go into the
more techie details.
One is called Material
Science-- this
is tomorrow morning at
11:00-- and the other
is Material Witness.
Material Science is
an overview of sort
of the entire space, kind of
a deeper dive of everything
I've just talked about.
And Material Witness
is a use case
where Romain and I wrote
particular apps using
these APIs and then talk
about how they were actually
implemented and how
the technology works.
The sessions in
your schedule right
now probably have
different names
because we were
withholding the material
name until after the keynote,
but the real names will
be out there very soon.
So check those out,
and there's also
an I/O Byte on activity
transitions in particular
that you can check out as well.
In Support Lib, there's the
RecyclerView and the CardView
stuff that I talked about.
There's also other capabilities,
including palette capabilities
for doing color sampling stuff.
This was mentioned
in the keynote.
Matias was talking
about that this morning.
There's RoundedBitmapDrawable.
This comes into play in
things like CardView.
It's very useful.
ViewPropertyAnimator.
This was done as more
of an implementation
detail of getting RecyclerView
animations to work.
And NotificationCompat is
useful for Android Wear stuff.
And we're onto WebView, where
we have updated to Chromium,
build M36, which enables
various useful web standards,
so you now have WebGL,
and the other things
listed on the slide.
Check out the I/O
Byte "What's New In
WebView" for more
detailed information.
On the graphic side,
there is an update
to OpenGL ES 3.1 with new
compute shaders and new shader
language capabilities.
We have bindings in
the SDK as well as NDK,
and obviously it's backward
compatible with OpenGL ES
2 and 3, as they usually are.
And you can say use
feature in your manifest
to specify this version exactly.
The other important
thing to mention
was also mentioned by
Dave Burke in the keynote.
It's the Android extension pack.
We basically collected a bunch
of extensions that are really
useful and powerful together and
sort of bring the platform up
to the current state of,
say, console gaming hardware.
And all of these
come as a bundle,
and we're working with
partners to enable
one and all of these
extensions together.
And there will probably be
a mechanism in the future
for you to ask for this
particular capability, which
basically gives you the
whole sandbox of capabilities
altogether.
Lots of useful stuff in
there, including tessellation,
enhanced geometry shaders,
and texture compression
would be nice.
Camera and audio space.
There's a couple of talks
I would suggest you go to
for the actual details
on this, but some image
processing capabilities, also
some audio data type buffering
information that I
couldn't possibly address,
because I don't know.
So I would suggest that you
go to the talks instead.
And in the meantime,
listen to Dan.
DAN SANDLER: You can
take a breath now.
CHET HAASE: Yay.
DAN SANDLER: Right.
So related to the audio
is a whole new set of APIs
to effectively replace
RemoteControlClient.
If you've ever
built a media player
and you've dealt with
transport controls,
you know about
RemoteControlClient.
Here to the rescue is
MediaSession and its friend
MediaController.
These are two new classes
and a bunch of other support
code in the platform to allow
you to make multiple playback
sources, and multiple
transport controllers,
and wire them all together.
The nice thing about
MediaController
is that it works from
a non-UI process,
so you can be running this
entirely in the background
if you need to do control of
an ongoing playback stream
from there, extract
metadata, things like that.
And we use that in
the system UI as well.
We'll talk about that a
little bit later in the talk.
MediaSession hooks up
to your playback stream
and essentially handles those
transport control requests
in much the same way that
you're already accustomed to.
And you'll talk to the
MediaSession manager
to work with those.
Great new tools, all on
android.media.session.
So you want to check those out.
I will segue from here into
all the other good stuff that's
in the framework, if it doesn't
fall under the green category.
CHET HAASE: It's the
non-visual framework stuff.
DAN SANDLER: That's
right, except that I'm
sure there's going to
some visual stuff here,
like right here
at the beginning.
So recent documents and tasks.
You saw this in the keynote.
Our recent apps interface in the
system UI is not just for apps
anymore.
We're now encouraging
your app to break apart
different components
of the experience
into different
tasks or documents.
We sort of call this a more
document-centric interface.
So you see in the
screen shot here
we've got a couple of
different web sessions,
essentially web documents
that are showing up
as different cards in
the recents experience.
And so this gives the user
a much greater ability
to shift back and forth between
different tasks on one device.
Go ahead.
CHET HAASE: Yeah,
I was gonna say,
this came up in the keynote when
they were talking about Chrome.
There was a web
session where they
were talking about different
tabs in the recents,
and this is the capability
that enables that.
DAN SANDLER: That's right.
So you can start a new
document at any time
by throwing in
Flag_Activity_New_Document
into that intent.
You can also mark your activity
that way in the manifest
to say this is always going
to start a new document.
Lots of other APIs that
we didn't have room
for on the slide.
You should definitely
check it out.
Also in the system
UI, you can now
do more with the status bar.
In KitKat, we introduced
a translucent status bar,
which was great for wallpaper
experiences and things that
wanted to go full bleed.
The problem that
we struggled with
was that gradient that we put in
there to protect the status bar
and navigation icons didn't
work great in every situation.
It's not a lot of space.
We didn't want to
overlap the app window.
We didn't know what was going
to be in the app window region.
So in the L Developer
preview, you'll
be able to see that you
can do a lot of things
with the status bar that
you couldn't do before,
particularly change
the color to something
that matches your application's
color branding, and so forth.
You can use a solid
color there, or you
can use a completely
transparent status bar,
and then it's up
to you to make sure
that all the status bar icons,
all the navigation bar icons
still look great.
But as you can see here
in the screen shot,
that gives us the opportunity
in Google Now Launcher
to create a nice, long gradient
that both protects the icon
so the user can see
them and gives you
a really nice transition
into the content.
Check it out.
You heard about power
a bunch in the keynote.
And we'll talk a little
bit about it here.
There's so much more to
look into under the heading
of Project Volta.
The first thing you'll see is
that there's a battery stat
service that you can
ask from ADB to give you
all kinds of gory details
about where the power is
going on the system,
what kind of power events
there have been, and
break it down by UID,
as well as looking
at the global story.
There's a tool in the SDK
called Battery Historian, which
I believe Dave Burke
mentioned, that gives you
sort of a trace view
like HTML graph output.
You feed it a bug report, and
it will tell you essentially
what happened to
all of the power
in that device
over that session.
It's incredibly,
incredibly useful.
Just a quick example of how
to talk to these things,
you can talk to batterystats
and say, oh, you
want to turn it on, you want
to enable the full history,
clear out all the stats,
take a bug report,
and then you stuff it
into the historian,
and you get out this
great piece of graphics
that you can use to understand
where those coulombs went.
Another thing that
helps with power,
and this was also touched on
a little bit in the keynote,
is JobScheduler.
We're going to go a
little bit deeper here.
It's pretty common
that you've got
an app that wants to
do some work later--
sometime in the background,
sometime when it's plugged in,
sometime when you have access
to an unmetered high speed
network.
So you can do all
this today, right?
You probably do in your app.
You wake up periodically,
check the conditions,
and then go back to sleep if
the situation isn't right.
That's not super
efficient because you
are waking up the device
just to check to see
if it's a good time
to wake up the device.
JobScheduler is here to help.
It wraps it all
up into something
that the system can
do and essentially
call back your job when
certain conditions are met.
And you see a little
bit of code here.
The interesting part
here is that you specify
the capabilities
you need, and then
you just give it
a component name,
and you'll get that
component name called
when the time is right.
Very handy.
Also in the framework,
some improvements
to the Storage Access
Framework, which
we introduced in
KitKat in API 19.
Previously if you wanted
to pop up a file browser
and ask for a directory,
you couldn't do it.
Now you can.
Once an app receives
a whole directory
from the picker in this
way, you can actually
explore the entire
subtree of documents
and do whatever you need to
do with that whole directory.
Also in our framework are some
new things around networking.
A couple of different topics.
First one is multi-networking.
We talked a little
bit about JobScheduler
being handy for doing some work
later under a particular kind
of condition.
What if you need to do work now?
Your service is running now,
your app is running now,
but you need to open a
socket on a link that
has some particular feature--
some carrier future you need,
needs to have SMS
capability, it needs
to be unmetered, and so forth.
ConnectivityManager now
supports the ability
to handle these
network requests.
You say requestNetwork, and
you give it a call back.
Inside that call back,
you will find out
when a network meeting your
criteria becomes available,
and then you can
use that network
object to look up hosts and
open sockets on that link
specifically.
The other nice
thing about the call
back, and this is very cool,
you get warnings, when possible,
when the network is
about to go down.
This allows you to actually do
a graceful handoff in your app
from one link to another.
Oh, you're about to lose
Wi-Fi because you're
leaving its range.
We're just going to
move this over, rebuild
the stream on cellular with
no interruption to the user.
Also under the banner of
networking is Bluetooth.
We introduced in 4.3
Bluetooth Low Energy.
In L, we are now adding
peripheral device support
to BLE.
So you can provide
services and scan
for services pursuant to
the way that Bluetooth LE
peripheral devices do
that sort of thing.
Check out the Android Bluetooth
LE package for more on that.
Finally, under networking,
we have NFC changes.
NFC has been a little hard to
use for users, a little hard
to use for developers.
We're trying to remove
all those pain points.
We're now showing Android
Beam in the Share menu
to make it easier to go
ahead and start an NFC
transmission from
the user standpoint.
From an app standpoint,
I don't know
if you've ever had a
situation where you're
trying to pop up a
dialog saying now hold
your phones closer together.
Now you can actually
specifically
start a Beam
operation anytime you
want with NfcAdapter.invokeBeam.
Another thing that has been
a little harder than it needs
to be is creating a very simple
piece of text to push over NFC.
Now there's a method on
NdefRecord to let you do that.
And there's a bunch of
new CardEmulation stuff
that I can't begin to explain
because, as Chet explained,
we don't know what it is.
So you should check that out.
And now as a sub head
of the frameworks,
we're going to talk
about notifications.
There's a lot to
talk about here.
CHET HAASE: It's a visual
side of the non-visual side.
DAN SANDLER: The visual side
of the non-- that's right.
It's layers.
There's a lot to
talk about here.
It's so key to what we're
doing with L for the user.
There's a lot to talk
about with notifications.
Also, it's an area
of my expertise,
and I have the
clicker, so we're going
to talk about it for a while.
I'm going to look at four
different categories, how
they look, how they work.
We're going to talk
about how that interacts
with the lock screen
and some privacy
features we've added to
make that work for everyone,
additional metadata that every
app needs to start putting
into its notifications to
make sure you're ready for L,
and then finally we'll touch
on Wear just a little bit.
They've got great talks
later in the program,
but I wanted to just mention
some of those interactions.
So first, the new style
notifications in L.
We should take a
quick look back.
These are the different
versions we've
had just in the last five years.
We've had a little
bit of evolution.
I don't know if you can
see the differences there.
CHET HAASE: We're getting
blacker and blacker-- how--
DAN SANDLER: It's a dark time
for the rebellion right there
at the end.
Here we have
notifications in L. We've
moved to the material style.
Let's go through and take
a look at the pieces here.
So first I want to
show you that we
are in fact using
the material theme.
We are in line with the rest
of the material design system
that we're introducing
for Android with L.
We've got these card-shaped
backgrounds that cast shadows.
The foreground is now
dark text, dark icons,
and the background
is this light color.
I should point out at this
point, if you've been following
the icon guidelines, there are
no new icon guidelines again,
by the way.
Trying to keep that going.
But if you've been following
the icon guidelines,
you should now have small
icons for notifications
and for actions that
are effectively masks.
And in L, we're actually
going to treat them as masks.
We're just going to use those
to draw in the correct color.
As Chet was alluding
earlier, that's
something we're trying
to do more of in L.
So if you have any opacity baked
into your icons right now, now
is the time to get rid of it.
Those should be full opacity,
white on transparent icons
everywhere.
The next thing I want to
draw your attention to
is this accent color.
This really looks
great and can really
make a notification pop
out and showcase, again,
that sort of color
story that you
may be trying to
tell with your app.
It's just one method on
the builder, setColor,
and it fills that
nice circle right
behind the small icon
on the notification
inside that layout.
I should point out that if you
have a large icon in the past,
we've kicked that small
icon, that important symbolic
representation of what
that notification's about,
we've kicked it over
kind of to the side,
where nobody notices it.
Now we're going to
keep that color circle,
we're going to keep
that visual story,
and we're gonna shrink it
down to a little badge that
goes right in front
of the large icon.
So it's always right where
the user expects to see it.
And then finally, it
just bears mentioning
that everything else
you know and love
about Android notifications
is still alive and well
and showcased great in
the L developer preview.
Expanded views, action buttons,
and as always in Android,
if what you need it
extends beyond what we've
been able to come up
with in our templates,
customer remote views are
there for you and available.
Now, I will say that one of the
things that people have said
to us is, well, OK,
that's all fine and well,
but I have to make a media
player, and for media players,
people expect
transport controls,
and then I have to go deal with
custom remote views and all
that pain.
We've been suffering along with
that basically since Honeycomb.
No longer.
We have a new template
for you, the first one
since Jellybean-- MediaStyle.
Material design finally
comes to media playback.
If you use this template, you
will opt into, essentially,
the design created just for
you by the Android UX team,
designing something
that will look great
both on the lock screen and in
the regular notification shade.
One other thing that
you'll notice about this
is that the accent color
fills the entire background
of the card.
CHET HAASE: It's orange.
DAN SANDLER: It is orange.
I wanted to make sure they could
see it from the cheap seats.
What am I saying?
This is Google I/O.
There are no cheap seats.
The accent color
fills the entire card,
and that helps it
pop out when you're
looking at the lock screen.
That's where your
media is coming from.
For the first time, we're
going to let you actually
use up to six action icons.
In fact, you could
always attach up to six,
we just only show
you the first three.
If you're using MediaStyle,
you'll get all six,
and we draw them as
little transport controls
here, which is super handy.
And in fact, we even let
you use one or two of those
in the compact form
of the notification,
again, to make
sure that wherever
you see that notification, it's
a great place to play and pause
media.
There's a custom ProgressBar
that fits with the theme,
but most importantly, you don't
need to use RemoteViews anymore
just to do simple
media playback.
I mentioned a little bit earlier
that there's a MediaSession
API.
There's also a bit
of the MediaStyle
that allows you to attach
your MediaSession token right
into the notification, which
is going to tell the system UI,
hey, this thing is
playing back media
right now, which is
going to be important
as we start to do things like
integrating more metadata
from that track, more metadata
from that ongoing playback,
into the system UI.
So for example, if you take
a look at the L Developer
preview, you'll see that
album art is regrettably not
showing on the lock
screen right now.
I was working on
that on the plane.
I couldn't quite
get it done in time.
I'm sorry.
But when we have it in L,
it will use this connection
to MediaSession to
get that metadata
right out of your ongoing
play back in real time.
Very quickly I want to
show you a wall of code,
because everybody loves that.
The important thing
about this is just
to note that most of these
APIs here are the existing
notification APIs that
you know and love.
They're the five actions that
are in the demonstration there.
I'm setting the color, and
then right there at the bottom
we're doing
Notification.MediaStyle,
which lets you attach
the media token
and then pick which
of the actions
to show in the compact form.
Something else you
saw in the keynote,
it kind of went by
quickly, and I really
should have put a video in here.
So it went by so quickly, it
disappeared from this slide.
Heads-up notifications
is something
that we've added to L to make
it easier for important things
to get in front of the user
without actually taking you out
of context.
So in the past, if a
phone call comes in,
you're in the middle
of playing a game,
that activity is paused,
that activity goes away.
If it was a multiplayer
game, that's
a great way to cause
somebody's game
to freeze so that you can
tag them or what have you.
No longer.
Heads-up notifications are the
new way for important things
to get the user's attention
without stealing focus away
from the app.
When that pops up,
you can look at it,
you can decide to ignore it,
you can decide to swipe it away,
you can decide to just push
it back into the notification
shade without swiping it
away, or you can act on it
by clicking one of
the action buttons.
We're using this for things that
the user needs to deal with,
the user needs to see.
So high priority notifications
will show up there.
Notifications that
involve people,
we'll talk about that
in the metadata section.
Similarly about
notifications that buzz,
make noise, or that would
use the full screen intent,
which is the way, of course,
that phone calls and alarms
and things like that would take
over your whole screen just
from a notification.
Let's take a little time and
talk about the lock screen.
So this is a big part of L.
You saw this in the keynote.
We heard you like notifications,
so we put your notifications
in your lock screen.
It's there any time
you want to look at it.
Why would we bother doing this?
What is the point of this?
Pre-L, the workflow of
your phone going off,
your phone buzzing
in your pocket
is you hear it buzz, you hear it
ding, you reach in, you take it
out of your pocket, you turn
it on, unlock the screen,
pull down the
notification shade.
By the time you've gotten
through all those gauntlets,
you've forgotten what
you came there for,
and there's some-- five other
things-- your email was sitting
there before you pulled
down your notifications,
and you're already distracted.
In L, you hear the phone buzz,
you take it out and turn it on,
and that's it.
It's right there.
It's completely glanceable for
everyone using an L device.
But what about privacy?
So for many users,
the design that we
showed in the keynote, the
design I just described,
is a perfect trade-off.
It's OK for you to allow
your notification content
to show up on your lock
screen because that's
super useful to you.
Unauthorized users are still not
be able to get into your phone
without authenticating,
but that doesn't
work for everyone or
every IT department,
particularly in a bring
your own device scenario.
So we've introduced
something in L
called notification visibility.
This is a new privacy
feature for notifications
specifically about how they
interact with the lock screen.
It lets apps specify what
is safe to show where.
It lets users
specify whether they
care about this
level of privacy,
and device policy can
be involved as well.
So to explain
this, I have to dig
into the spheres of visibility.
I need an echo, like
a reverb for that.
Spheres of visibility.
This is the public sphere.
This is all the things anyone
can do with your phone.
You can do it, Chet can do
it if he picks up your phone,
the person who picks up
the phone at the bar when
you've left it on the bar stool.
These are all the things that
you can do from the lock screen
without authenticating.
The circle inside, these
are the private things.
These are the things that only
you can do with your phone,
because you know
how to get into it.
You can authenticate.
You can get past the
lock screen and get
into your notifications, your
email, your apps, your games,
your data, your
pictures, and so forth.
So in the notification
visibility world,
we call this central--
this ring of the things
that only you are supposed to
be able to see-- visibility
private.
A notification that is
marked visibility private
is very much like an Android
notification up until now.
That is to say we don't
leak anything about it
on a lock screen where the
user has said that they
care about this sort of thing.
All you show is the
icon, and in fact, in L
we also show the application
name to help fill the space.
If you set a notification
to be visibility public,
you're saying this notification
has nothing sensitive.
It's completely unobjectionable.
It's the weather, right?
It's your device
is low on battery.
This is not information that
is personally sensitive.
It's safe to show
on any lock screen,
no matter whether
the user is concerned
with that level of security.
There's a little ring here
that I didn't mention before,
which is the things that
are private that you
can kind of see on
the lock screen.
I told you that in L, we
continue Android's tradition
of showing notification
icons, even
if you haven't authenticated.
So one of the things
that you can do now in L,
I'll show you an
example in a minute,
is say, if you've got a
private notification, where
the user doesn't want to see
all that sensitive information
on the lock screen,
you can provide
a substitute, a
public version that
lets you provide a redacted
form of that same notification
for a sensitive lock screen.
We'll see an example
on the next slide.
I do want to mention
also that now that we've
created all these circles,
all these pretty builds
in the slide, there's one
little spot that's left,
which is things that only
you know are even there.
We didn't have an opportunity
to do this in Android before,
so we've created the
third and final visibility
level, which is
visibility secret.
If you post a notification
that is visibility secret,
it doesn't appear on
the lock screen at all.
So if it's
particularly sensitive
and you would like to
get notifications for it
but you don't really want
anybody else to know that it's
installed, visibility
secret is for you.
OK, here's that
promised example.
So let's say the user has
said, this is important to me.
They've set up a pattern
or PIN on their phone,
and they've said, when
the device is locked,
I want to hide the
sensitive notification
content from the lock screen.
If you have a notification
that is visibility public,
this is what you see
on the lock screen.
I may or may not have
overseen that on a lock screen
somewhere.
Anybody can see
this notification
whether they've
authenticated or not,
whether the user cares
about security or not.
This is safe for everyone.
CHET HAASE: I don't think so.
DAN SANDLER: Well, so
this is why you would say,
maybe this is something
that's visibility private.
A chat app is the
sort of thing that
maybe is supposed
to be personal.
CHET HAASE: Should have been.
DAN SANDLER: Should have been.
Really.
You should think
about that next time.
So if you have a visibility
private notification
on a lock screen
where the user has
said hide sensitive
notification content,
this is the experience you'll
see by default under the L
Developer preview-- icon,
app name, nothing else.
So if you as an app want to
provide a better experience,
you can provide that
redacted version.
You can create a public
version of the notification,
you say setPublicVersion,
you construct
a whole new
notification object that
is a substitute for that
one to be shown only
on the lock screen.
And so in this case,
we've corrected,
we've changed the app
name a little bit.
We've added an exclamation
mark because that
makes people feel cool.
And we've actually
given the user
some interesting information.
You have a new message.
It's not simply something is
happening from this app, which
could be I have a sync
problem, or you need to pay $5
or whatever, it's
actually giving you
a little bit of information, but
it's not sensitive information.
So it's compatible
with the user's wishes.
And then finally there's
that visibility secret,
and those things
wouldn't show up at all.
Now of course, if the
user goes and says,
well, when my device
is locked, I actually
don't mind seeing all
my notifications there,
then you see the same thing.
It essentially is every
notification is public.
We talked a little
bit about metadata,
about adding people
and things like that.
We actually talked about
metadata in KitKat.
We've started to introduce
some new features to be
able to stick more
information onto notifications
for the benefit of the system UI
and any notification listeners
that the user may have enabled.
Well, we've got more for you
in the L Developer preview.
One of the reasons that we want
to do sorting a lot better.
There's limited space
to show notifications
on the lock screen.
In the past, sorting things
chronologically, maybe
with a little bit of priority,
it's good-- it's not great.
We're doing better in
L. So one of the things
that you can do in L to make
sure that notifications get
sorted in the right
way so that users
are seeing the most
important stuff
first is attach, first of
all, a notification category.
We have a number
of categories that
are in the notification API.
It's a set of essentially
a global partition
of notification space.
If what you have
doesn't fit, you
don't have to set a category.
But if your thing
is an incoming voice
call, or an incoming video call,
or you've got an alarm clock
app, high timely team, then
you can tag your notifications
with that category and
make sure that the system
UI knows what kind
of thing it is.
And as we improve L, we will be
able to do more things to sort
of mute things that are
not relevant to the user's
current context.
We'll use that
category to do it.
There's a new extra key
for the notification
extras called EXTRA_PEOPLE.
This is for you to be able to
say this notification relates
to a person that the
user might care about.
What do you put in here?
You put in a URI from
the contacts provider,
or you put in a telephone
number if that's all you have
and you're not integrating
with Android contacts,
or you put in an email address.
Whatever you have, you
put in EXTRA_PEOPLE,
and then system UI can
take a look at that
and say, hey, that
involves somebody.
I might want to boost that up.
And the other stuff
is still important.
The timestamp, whether there's
a fullScreenIntent, priority,
whether it makes
noise, all these things
are going to give the
system UI new tools
to be able to know what things
are most important to show
to the user first.
Most importantly,
though, for developers
is to give that
user that control.
Let the user turn
off notifications,
let the user change the
properties of notifications.
You don't want to run the
risk of the user banning
notifications using the
system Settings app, a very
popular feature that we
introduced in Jellybean.
And when you do give users
choices about notifications,
when you give the users
that activity that
lets them configure
everything, put that activity
into your manifest
with the new intent
category listed on the slide,
NOTIFICATION_PREFERENCES.
And we will actually link to
that notification preferences
page right from system Settings.
So if you go into
Settings, Notifications,
you'll be able to jump
straight into the apps that
have notification preferences
that the user can control.
Briefly I want to mention that
Wear is key to the notification
story in L and vice versa.
It's very much like
the L lock screen.
It's super glanceable,
except with Wear
it's already out of your pocket.
Your phone app's notifications
appear on wearables
automatically.
They get bridged there.
You've seen this in the keynote.
You saw this as part of the Wear
unveiling a couple months ago.
Notification.WearableExtender
is the place
where all the APIs exist
for you to customize
the appearance of
that notification
specifically on the
wearable device.
Split it up into multiple pages,
group notifications together,
and things like that.
And as you get into more
advanced Wear development
and you're developing
apps for Wear itself,
to run on the watch, you'll
see that it uses notifications
there, too.
In fact, the notification
manager on the watch
is the thing that
manages those cards
that you see in the wearable UI.
So you'll use the same old
Notifications API to interact
with Wear from on
the wearable itself.
There are I/O sessions that you
should definitely check out.
Tomorrow at 10:00, the Android
developers on the Wear team
are going to take you through
all these APIs in detail,
and there's an I/O
Byte on YouTube
about building
these UIs as well.
OK, other important stuff.
Take it away, Chet.
CHET HAASE: OK,
I took my breath.
I'm back.
DAN SANDLER: OK.
CHET HAASE: So
other random stuff
that we couldn't actually find
an appropriate bucket for.
So here it is.
ART, we heard about
this in the keynote.
You've heard about it before.
It came out in KitKat
as an optional run time,
and now it is the runtime.
I had thought
previously, oh, it's
the one that's
enabled by default,
and then I was
corrected this week.
It is the one.
In fact, Dalvik?
What Dalvik?
Everything is ART,
and it's a good thing.
Faster runtime, the ability to
actually pre-compile this stuff
so that it's running faster.
A lot more intelligence
going on in that runtime
than we had before.
And one of my favorites is
the increased capabilities
for garbage collection.
So less frequent pauses and
shorter durations of those
pauses mean a better ability to
actually hit your frame rate,
particularly for animations.
If you had a GC pause of
10 milliseconds, which
was sometimes common,
unfortunately,
in Dalvik, depending on what
was going on in the system,
that could just push you right
over the boundary of a frame,
and you'd skip a
frame, and the user
would see a hiccup
in the animation.
Now if you have pause times
of around 2 milliseconds,
then it's much more
probable that you're
going to stay within that
16 millisecond boundary,
and it's not going
to affect your frame
rate or those animations.
So faster, better,
newer, cooler.
Check it out, in particular
go to the ART talk.
That's Thursday, tomorrow
morning, at 10:00.
And also, go to the
Sandbox, and they're
giving an ongoing talk,
GC and Jank in ART.
Talk to them.
I think there's also
documentation that's
coming out on the web if
it's not there already.
So lots of stuff
to check out there.
Oh, one of my favorite things
too is the moving collector.
The ability to actually
move stuff around
in the heap, which
caused some of the delays
that we saw before, that
things couldn't move.
So then the heap
would get fragmented,
and then it got
harder and harder
to find space for things that
you needed to newly allocate.
Well, now we can actually
collect the heap and move
stuff around when that
app is backgrounded.
So very powerful capability,
linked with the ability
to then take really
large objects like bitmap
and put those in
a set aside space
so that the really large
objects aren't taking up room
in the common space where all
the little tiny objects need
to go.
So that's part of the reason
why we have much smaller pause
times for allocations as well
as collections, because it's
much faster for us
to find the space
that we need when
we actually need it.
Android TV?
DAN SANDLER: There's a
great talk about this,
let's see when it is.
That's this afternoon.
Yes, this afternoon.
All about Android TV.
There's an I/O Byte on YouTube.
The message from
the Android TV team
is this-- you saw it in
the keynote-- there's
gonna be one app.
You're gonna produce
one app, and it's
going to run great
on every device that
calls itself Android--
phones, tablets, TVs.
When your app is ready for
that 10 foot experience
they talked about
in the keynote,
there's an additional
intent category
you can toss into your manifest
to move your app up so that it
shows up on that main panel,
that main rail inside the TV
launcher UI.
You can still launch your
app if it's not there,
but when it's ready for
that TV experience, that's
how you move it up.
More info at d.android.com/tv.
CHET HAASE: Enterprise,
the main thing I'd say here
is go to the Sandbox
and attend the talk
on frameworks for enterprise
and device management,
and Ben will give
you more information
about what's going
on for enterprise.
They talked about
it a little bit,
Sundar was talking
about it in the keynote,
about managed
profiles, the ability
to actually have
your IT department,
let's say, in a
BYOD world actually
manage what's on the device.
And then this division
between the device owner,
the person actually
using the device,
and the profile owner, which
might be the organization
that that user is a part of.
And the ability to do
that in enterprises
is increasingly important.
There's new APIs in
DevicePolicyManager
that enable this, and
there's also an app
that they're working on
for pre-L releases that
will enable some of these
capabilities as well.
Android tools.
I spoke to one of the
people on the Tools team
and got the brief
take on exactly what's
new and exciting
in the tool space.
And then I said, OK,
great, I will talk about it
in the session.
He said, actually, we're
going to talk about it
in Thursday's so please don't.
So go to their session
tomorrow at 9:00
and learn what's new in tools.
Play Services.
There's an excellent session
coming on this afternoon.
So we have the Wear
Data API, much more
information about
what's going on there.
Games, capabilities, the
capabilities of Quests,
as well as saved
games in the cloud.
So you can actually save your
share state between devices
much more easily.
New Drive capabilities,
new Wallet capabilities,
increased analytics
for your apps.
Much more that I didn't
want to get into this slide,
and they can tell you much
more about that at the session
if you go there.
And some other stuff
that didn't even
fit into our other
grab bag category.
Security.
SELinux is now in
enforcing mode.
I would encourage you
to go to the "Secure
Development on Android" I/O Byte
on YouTube and check that out.
Get more information
about that, as well as
some other things in
the encryption area
that you can learn about.
And also in the
printing area, but I
would say just in general,
we have a new PdfRenderer
capability that allows
you to take PDFs and then
render them as bitmaps.
Very useful for
printing, and we use it
for the print preview, which
is now part of the release.
But you can use it in general
if that's a capability
that you need in
your application.
And most importantly,
the preview SDK.
What is it?
When is it coming out?
Tomorrow.
So here's some URLs.
d.android.com, actually /preview
is where you can get more
information about
the preview release,
as well as download the bits for
building against and download
system images for Nexus
5 and 7 minimally.
And that comes out
tomorrow, so please
get started developing today,
or-- yeah, there's the links.
Tomorrow.
Yeah.
Developed for the preview
release of L today, tomorrow.
And in the meantime, go to all
the I/O sessions, enjoy those,
and the I/O Bytes online are
being posted as of today.
And please, if you have
issues, please submit them.
The sooner the better, because
the sooner you submit them,
the better chance
we're going to have
of actually knowing
about them in time
to fix them for the
full on L release.
DAN SANDLER: And
we ran out of time.
CHET HAASE: We did
run out of time.
DAN SANDLER: We
planned it perfectly.
We have 17 seconds for
Q&A. So actually, we're
going to take Q&A downstairs
in the sandbox on the platform
level of the second
floor, right?
CHET HAASE: Yes.
We'll be there right after this
talk, and thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]